too many libertarians have been
terrified because they're afraid well I
might make a compromise and that would
make me dirty hi I'm Michael Moynihan
with Reason TV and today we are with Tom
G Palmer the author of realizing freedom
libertarian theory history and practice
a senior fellow at the Cato Institute
and vice president for international
programs at the Atlas Economic Research
Foundation
Tom welcome well thank you it's a
pleasure to be here
I give our viewers a an impression of
what you're trying to achieve with this
book what the sort of premise in this
book is I wanted to present a kind of
coherent picture of libertarian ideas
with two elements to it one is it's
important to respond to our critics so I
have some very appointed responses to
communitarians extrema gala Tyrians
socialist conservative communitarians
and so on because I think too many
occasions in the past defenders of
Liberty have retired from the field and
I think you need to push back the other
element was to show that Liberty is
about doing it's about implementing
freedom it's about realizing freedom not
just talking about or having seminars
about it those are important but it's
about going out and doing the hard work
of changing the world to realize a more
free more just society first piece in
this book that I saw was 1981 that's for
the sort of starting point is how are we
doing now in the period from when you
started writing these pieces to where we
are right now last couple years have
been really bad especially in the United
States the Bush administration now Obama
or the bowl bomber administration as I'd
like to think of it has been a
catastrophe but if you go back to 1981
there has been tremendous improvement
there's no more Soviet Union the Warsaw
Pact is is finished there's been this
worldwide spread of an awareness of
Liberty the internet communications have
generally had a very very positive
impact so I think that even though last
couple years have been really bad we're
living at one of the most free times in
human history but it's fragile this sort
of thing can be unwound and we should
look at the failures of the classical
liberals in the 19th century to prepare
for the 20th I worry that we might
become complacent in our Liberty and not
think about what is at stake that it is
in fact quite fragile
the rise of protectionism President
Obama just this week did something
unbelievably stupid and is now set off a
trade war with China he's at the tire
tariffs right yeah
and now the Chinese are talking about
chicken tariffs and odd will be a part
tariffs and so on nothing good will come
of this
it's very very dangerous and we need to
act quickly to defeat protectionism and
to assert the moral superiority of free
trade and free markets not just it's
more efficient it is it is morally
better and we need to take to the field
and take these people on you have a very
international perspective your pieces on
Russia and the Middle East it's Center
Latin America what can we be doing right
now to sort of help spread freedom in a
time where as you point out it's kind of
in a precarious situation that's a
really hard thing because they're kind
of very few a place to place but I'm
involved in 17 projects from 17
different languages Russian Chinese
Portuguese bahasa Arabic Persian and so
on and we're very active in all of those
with summer schools seminars teaching
getting people to understand these key
points Leonard read the founder of fie
had a good point he says we can't be
effective if we don't understand the
philosophy of Liberty and the
institutional foundations and rule of
law property limited government
toleration and so on but then also you
need to do something that's even harder
it's risky you need to take risks to be
willing to make proposals for real
change for free trade eliminating
tariffs which i think is really one of
the most important things this is the
time to push the free trade agenda the
Liberals of the 18th and 19th centuries
understood free trade leads to peace the
academic and scholarly research is now
overwhelming on this protectionism sets
the stage for war so we should be
proposing a rash radical free trade
agenda and this is something I've been
really promoting all over the world and
there are free trade campaigns now being
launched in India and Central
Asia in China Latin America and
elsewhere that's very important but then
the other thing is don't be so fearful
of taking risks becoming involved in the
process of policy change including
politics when that's appropriate in
various countries too many libertarians
have been terrified because they're
afraid while I might make a compromise
and that would make me dirty
well the question is do you want to
change the world you want to move toward
a freer world then you have to engage it
and you can't be in this little corner
saying well we're going to be secure and
ineffective ineffective people usually
feel very good about themselves it's the
people who affect change we're the ones
who have doubts who make mistakes but
that's how you do it you have to take
risks and it's obviously gonna differ
from place to place our colleagues in
China understand where the line is that
gets you arrested and they try and get
up really close to it but generally
better not to end up in prison
but you want to move where that line is
and it has been moving over time
partly because one of those things that
is helping push that line as you
mentioned is trade right now posts
financial crises do you see a problem do
you see us backsliding in any ways on
trade I mean obviously you mentioned
bama's tire tariffs we have of course
the NAFTA issues with Mexican trucks on
the road etc is this a difficult time
when you say right now is the time for
more free trade i remember what rahm
emanuel said you never want a serious
crisis to go to waste and that's what
all the protectionists are saying right
now and they are really geared up the
consequence of those policies would be a
repeat of smoot-hawley crash the world
economy 1930 Hoover signs that bill US
foreign export trade collapsed as a
consequence within two years total
volume of world trade was down by
two-thirds that's a substantial amount
of what the Great Depression was now we
run that risk again and talking about a
time when there
a full frontal assault by the Naomi
Klein's of the world on free markets on
classical liberalism this seems a very
important piece give us an idea what the
most common misperception that that you
tackle here and you know why it's
important that we fight back against
these things one of the issues that I
address is whether the market is immoral
and that's an important underlining
element of this attack people in
business only care about profits they
don't care about other people they don't
care about others
so that's fundamentally wrong markets
rests on respect for other people I
could just go out and take stuff I'm a
fairly strong guy and I'm pretty
aggressive and I'm fairly tough if I
wanted to I could go take things from
people I don't do that because I respect
them that's what property rights means
and if I want something someone else has
I induced them to give it to me
now you can beg that's not generally
very effective you can give them
something else that they want more so
the market economy rests fundamentally
on respect for other people it's also
the case that there's nothing
particularly selfish about the market
there's been a misunderstanding of Adam
Smith in this regard people going to the
market are partly concerned about others
partly concerned about themselves but
either even mother Teresa tried to get
the lowest price for blankets and
medicines to help other people the
market was what made possible the
charity of the charitable people as well
because they want to economize they want
to find the lowest price as HB act and a
British philosopher put it he says
running a business at a loss is an
especially stupid way of being
charitable what is the future of freedom
and in in the context of your book
realizing freedom how do we realize
freedom now in a in a situation that
that look so grim especially for
economic freedom well first off it's not
all the same every place in the world
looks like the Germans might end up with
a little bit of belt-tightening in their
government they have not taken some of
the crazy measures that we've seen
proposed in this country maybe just
turning on the printing presses but a
little bit more restrained in some of
Europe I think that we're in for a very
tough slog but if people make it
that they do not go along with us and
one thing that's come up is is this
so-called public option that was a term
that was focus-grouped
as they say they went through every name
for socialism and people didn't like it
so this public option people that that
sounds ok whatever that is it's
socialism it's a state-run medical
system and do not believe for a minute
that if we get that it's really going to
be self-financing
that's rubbish and everybody knows it
this is a time for people to stay in a
per say no way and even to be angry
about it I'm not opposed to anger when
injustice and foolishness is being
proposed so I'm all in favor being angry
in the United States about the direction
the country is taking I think they
should have been angry three years ago
when Bush was doing it Tom Palmer author
of most recently realizing freedom
libertarian theory history and practice
thank you for joining us thank you Mike